quanti di voi sono degli influencer
alzate la mano pochi quasi nessuno non
siete degli influencer bene nemmeno io
io sono una che ha imparato a farsi ben
influenzare solo una che ha imparato a
farsi consigliare
io leggo moltissimo in rete e ringrazio
molto quanti hanno deciso di raccontare
in rete ciò che sanno perché è così che
io imparo cose nuove
io non sono influencer io sono un cavo
un cavo che collega io sono un cavo che
collega e trasmette informazioni i cavi
sono fatti di anime e di materiale
isolante nel momento qui trasportano le
informazioni trasmettono energia si
scaldano e io mi scaldo quando trasmette
energia quando trasmetto qualcosa io
faccio in modo che questa membrana
isolante che mi separa dagli altri si
assottigli in questo modo io mi avvicino
ad altri cavi quando cercavo l'immagine
giusta che rappresentasse questo cavo ho
trovato il cavo giusto questo è il cavo
del citofono a quattro cavi comuni più
un quinto che quello che apre la porta
perché i cavi ci connettono connettono e
ci portano in posti nuovi
questo cavo che poi sono io e anche cavo
che raccoglie che raccoglie informazioni
io sono cava come quella bacinella che
mia nonna metteva al sole con l'acqua
per farmi il bagnetto
sono cresciuta in un paese in cui era
comune non avere il bagno in casa non
vengono da un luogo né da un'epoca
connessi ho comprato il mio primo
computer nel 1990
non sono una nativa digitale i nativi
digitali sono quelli che sono nati circa
dopo il 1985 ci sono delle differenze da
paese a paese ma comunque sei fuori di
dieci anni i nativi digitali hanno
l'accesso diretto alla tecnologia ea
internet quando ero piccola internet non
c'era il mio primo computer l'ho
comprato nel 99 e avevo 25 anni ma 15
anni ho chiesto a mio nonno di regalarmi
un corso per imparare un linguaggio di
programmazione non aveva un computer non
aveva un computer e non l'ho avuto per
anni
da lì in poi ho sempre scritto solo
carta e penna
ho fatto in modo che comunque le persone
mi influenzassero e nel 2003 ho aperto
un blog dove racconto un sacco di fatti
miei e spesso anche cose sulla
comunicazione
io so esattamente che tipo di vita
voglio vivere lavoro compreso e non mi
chiedo mai in che cosa possano esservi
utili gli altri quando l'incontro nel
momento in cui incontrò gli altri sono
sono felice sono contenta di aver
incontrato qualcuno e se mi piace farci
amicizia
ciò nonostante nonostante il fatto che
io non mi chieda mai se qualcuno potrà
essermi utile
io sono circondata da persone che mi
tengono compagnia quando faccio un passo
avanti verso la conquista del mondo
io non sono un influencer gli influencer
per quelli che prima non hanno alzato la
mano sono no non sono perché in questo
periodo sono polemiche in corso e
non c'è una definizione che posso darvi
che sia univoca sappiate santa che può
essere utile sapere che ognuno di noi ha
delle idee e delle opinioni
e queste idee queste opinioni
influenzano qualcuno
grazie a internet qualcuno in più
ognuno di noi trasmette delle
informazioni
ognuno di noi è un medium i mass media
sono mezzi attraverso i quali
diffondiamo a indistinti destinatari un
messaggio ognuno di noi è un media noi
trasmettiamo messaggi e quando ci
leggiamo solo online
pensateci anche voi siete tutti i più
simpatici più belli più spensierati più
magri leggendovi soltanto online
ecco io quando incontrò le persone è
visto che mi iscrivo a tutto e quindi le
persone sono ovunque mi piace metterle
in contatto tra loro quando si passano
le informazioni nascono sempre progetti
interessanti quando è stata l'ultima
volta che avete consigliato un libro
qualcuno è l'ultima volta che avete
detto a un amico di andare a vedere quel
film
e quando invece non vi è servito con un
parere un consiglio fosse anche soltanto
per sapere dove andare a mangiare con
gli amici una sera a cena
ecco ogni volta che scambiamo
informazioni
diamo consigli o chiediamo un parere in
spezziamo questa rete di contatti tra
noi e gli altri
io non sono al centro del mio network
io ne sono parte io sono un nodo perché
siamo una rete fatta di cavi che si
incrociano
io sono un nodo di questa rete che
trasmette informazioni ad altri a cosa
mi serve
stiamo costruendo un mondo migliore un
ecosistema fatto di cavi fatto di cavi
che si incrociano di nodi di persone che
parlano e di una trasmissione
di conoscenza che grazie alla rete che
adesso abbiamo l'occasione di fare
quindi se non siete nativi digitali come
me e non siete dell'influenza come non
lo sono io
potete essere un cavo per farlo dovete
connettervi agli altri dovete essere
cavo non usarlo quindi adesso girate
diverso il vostro compagno di posto
chiacchierate presentate vi fate
amicizia ok
adesso diventate un cavo
grazie per la compagnia